because over a hundred fifty thousand
plus women credit her not only to saving
their relationships but also to helping
them become desired terrace on the door
top three reasons now get this this will
blow your mind according to her how
traditional behavioral marriage
counseling can destroy your marriage
when I finally did get willing to
experiment with all these suggestions I
make my marriage like a little
laboratory and I just experimented trial
and error eight years and something
really magical emerged respect is so
important for men it's like oxygen in a
relationship for them ask any man that's
what and sometimes women can't
understand that completely contrary to
everything I'd ever read in Glamour
magazine how about you probably heard
this and then sometimes the body
language will come into it with the
little attitude say well he don't
deserve my respect yeah see I stood by
the professors of psychology couples who
received traditional behavioral marriage
counseling were separated within one
year you talk about something else being
an aphrodisiac tell us about this now
come to me and ask for help with their
relationships this is Kanye West
condition what's this Kanye West
condition he's back and he's doing all
these romantic sweet thoughtful thing